the last text my mom said to me was did
Beyonce have her babies yet I said I
don't know and she said you work at
BuzzFeed for the love of God
Costco had the most beautiful hanging
plants so I had to get to
smiley face me and my mom are going to
diet together so the last thing she
texted me is I am starving
I begged dad to get me a whopper from
Burger King but he didn't he's such an
[ __ ] the last thing that my mom
texted me is a kiss face emoji and a
heart emoji the last text my mom sent me
is stay on our health insurance the last
thing my mom texted me is that my
parents got approved to adopt a dog
named Hank the last thing my mom texted
me was I'm going to fire emoji devil
emoji so I'm going to hell my mom sent
me a picture of her and asked if her
concealer was too light
good morning are you up yet I asked her
if she would come to New York and she
was like you want me to visit you and
she was excited and then I said no I
want you to I want you to dog-sit but
she didn't respond to the head so I feel
a little guilty last thing my mom texted
me was a picture of damage that my dad
calls trying to DIY a dishwasher
installation and I said rough times okay
so my mom recently texted me the entire
lyrics to the songs father and daughter
by Paul Simon literally the entire song
there it is good still going so the last
text message I got from my mom was
actually a smiley face because she was
thanking me on being the biggest gift
that she has and because it's a craft
for dinner for Guatemalan Mother's Day
which is May 10th timmy was in the well
again my family's one dog constantly
escapes and we always joke that he's
going to rescue tippy from the well so
my dog got out again
that's it hey Christian yeah I think
it's a busy at work you probably
wouldn't answer the phone but I'm still
thrilled about that article so proud of
you very proud love you Mike
happy Mother's Day mom I love you mom
happy Mother's Day mom happy Mother's
Day mom
[Music]
Oh
Oh